hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival okay we just escaped from
hell oh so now Oh daylight I seem to be
escaping the abyss every time it's day
out so that's awfully nice still don't
know why I needed to go in there in the
first place but I'll let that slide we
have got more important things to worry
about at this time like why the hell did
I even come into these woods in the
first place
do I have some special connection with
these people I think not love the music
great environment as per yuge I'm on if
in case you guys were wondering I'm on
the fourth stage the fourth stage of
five hello number nine there must have
been some notes in in that underground
area that I missed leaving this know in
case you wake up tonight I'm going to
assume you don't remember what happened
I came over to check on you and found
you out in that park behind the house
you had a broken video camera with you
in a bag full of weird drawings I don't
know what happened out there but you're
safe now the doctors will help here will
help you okay ah that must be relating
to the first slender the eight pages
that that means that the first time that
I'm pretty sure that character is
referring to me I went out into the
woods and grabbed all the drawings off
the page or maybe I put the drawings up
there I don't know and I had a video
camera before which I'm sure is the
original imagining of why or how they
ventured out or she ventured out into
the woods but either way that's cool so
this is after the fact and this is the
same character and now cilenti's really
method
that's probably shouldn't go that way
just saying don't run straight off the
edge of the cliff I am i up here it's
because I'm cuckoo crazy pants
I am totes mix croats insane balls well
how am I gonna get down wait is there a
way to go over there I didn't think
there was I don't think so wait was I
even supposed to come down this way
where am I going I have no idea I have
no order okay I must have been a my must
have been supposed to go that way
because there's no way to go here
nice music bye bye very relaxing makes
me think that I'm almost not gonna die
almost no this is just going back
there's no other way to go here alright
it must have been must have been this
way maybe I did need to fall right off
the cliff oh you familiar footsteps
whatever there must have been a path
over here that I missed either that or
I'm going to run straight off the cliff
just because I can
ah I'm so stupid must have been some
some and it didn't that is big scenery
by the by ah here we go sorry I'm missus
I'm I'm such an I hold I hold I'm such
an aisle what's up there nothing follow
the path every time I try to explore it
always leads me astray seriously that is
a gigantic level I can't also can't tell
where the backdrop begins in the actual
scenery ends what's up this way
and it didn't don't straight up the
mountain I can really book it I mean not
when I need to but I can really book it
when I'm not being chased by Slendy and
anything up here hello hello huh there
must be some deeper reason for all of
this that's gotta be and I'm gonna get
to the bottom darker I can't tell
I'm gonna get to the bottom of it by
getting to the top of this mountain ha
ha did I just go in a circle oh damn it
I just went in a circle that's the path
back down there well oh here we go okay
number 10 glad you're feeling better but
that house is too close to the woods
it's too isolated you need to go
somewhere else I know a place that I
think will be safer for you to stay I'm
going to go with you because my house
doesn't feel safe anymore I nailed all
the windows shut but I still feel too
open I haven't slept in a few weeks
either until I'm so tired let's get out
of your Kate I promise I'll keep you
safe
okay now why am i finding all these
notes to me out in the woods I don't
know but I might have to go back after I
finish the game which and I don't think
I'm too far off from afterwards to see
if I can get all the notes Oh an active
flare someone's been by here recently
Oh joyous day I'm in the caves
once again I have dived oh good I
thought I was gonna be stuck in the
caves oh good alright what do we got
here I want to die why why do you wanna
die that's not good number 11 outside I
need to die before it catches me I'm
sorry for any part that is my fault
everything is leaking out the back of my
head hands up teeth please don't know
and I love them it's back now hide oh oh
oh it's justit's footstep noise is this
what the hell what is this is that the
person who makes all the drawings
okay he's here oh this is back in the
house
great oh this is why I needed to lock
the windows why didn't I do this during
the day
oh this I'm so bummed I'm so bummed
that's closed oh I'm so bored
that's why this thing was called
flashback again get out of here oh oh
wait this one's close to okay so random
windows are open close nice shot that
one's shut
that was shut right yes chef
okay this looks good this is great I
like this being trapped in a house why
who left the front fricking door open
open you [ __ ]
I see you
ha ha funny better not be in this house
shut up
closed damn it okay and why do I feel
the obsessive needs all right who's that
who's that what was it five of eight
come on let's make it through this game
has a serious deal with numbers and
patters play the piano yeah calm down
with a little relaxing piano chords back
door wide open
gah these damn kids don't know how to
paying for the electric Bhupati my Robin
Hayes and house kept the stairs you
[ __ ] I'm sorry cause if it took just a
little stressed right now
he was hiding with the music the music
okay enough I can't move I can't move I
can't move what can I know what happened
what happened I can't move oh no don't
tell me don't tell me
I found another bag I hate my life ah
what did i do I don't even know what I
did this time oh okay I guess I'll be
back
God cuz I can't even escape out of the
game now Viraj ah
okay we're back sorry about that I don't
know what I'm doing wrong I keep
breaking I just saw this though there is
some writing on the walls that has to do
with the tower and a cross down Slendy
man and something about a crossed out
tower can you see it I have no idea
escape question mark anyway don't know
what that's all about what let's try
this again I feel bad cuz I feel like
I'm disappointing you by finding all
these books I would be a great play
tester for a game because I'm so great
at finding bugs let's just do this get
up and yeah I know he's here can I
thank you
okay she's muttering to herself I can
hear that now don't let him in which is
not good all right cuz he's already in
and I'm going to try to hurry this time
maybe I can actually shut all the doors
and windows before he gets in it doesn't
matter now it's lending he's already in
front door wide open again can't believe
it
give me let me actually click on it
thank you very much yeah the interaction
mechanics don't work quite as well as
like same Nisha does but it's not that
shut up damn your piano
we got the ones over here this early I
haven't even come near to closing all of
them open up please
thank you no we don't want any we
already bought some cookies thank you
very much
okay he's already nearby which is bad so
let's try to close everything anything
in here no I can't tell cuz won't open
oh okay yes I agree
good bye thank you for showing up but
the party ended a while ago that's
there's no point he's already decide Oh
run don't bug out don't bug don't bug Oh
bug don't bug didn't bug thank goodness
gravy gracious gravy thank the Lord
thank the old it did not bug alright so
what does that mean is that another well
Sundy got her I don't even know if that
was me or of the other woman I'm not
sure there's two girls I'm not sure but
I don't I don't know I don't know I
think this might I think that might have
been the end of that chapter I'm not
exactly sure hey wait a minute
do you expect me to believe that someone
made an exact mirror of that on the
other side what you talking about Willis
that is absolutely bull oh okay okay so
anyway I think I think this is
approaching the end this might be the
last scene but then again I might be
wrong so I'm just gonna take it on a
whim here let's see if that's the way it
is so I'm gonna finish this up in the
next episode let's see if I can find one
last bug before we end this soap thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for more video since I've
done and as always I will see
Oh in the next video
Oh